今月初めしたようですお待たせしました2018年
お菓子銃手を禁止したとしなーめんを記述したとして28年
僕は僕は何を喫しすればいいのかわからなくなってしまったというわけで動画の
コメントに皆さんに何を軽視したらいいかのコメントを募ったんですけれどもその結果
が集まりましたので皆さんに紹介していこうと思いますけど
こうですねかぶってました中には潰すのコメントでぐっとが多かったやつとかあったん
でちょっとコメントの中で目立ったものと花王って思った奴をちょっとまずは紹介して
いこうと思います何を軽視するかは
それからだお弁当とか買い食いを禁止で自炊をする
これですねこれめちゃくちゃ多かったですお弁当とかイベの研修自炊をする
めちゃくちゃおいしい僕もしたい所であるんですけども
なぜ面倒とか指するかっていうとあの時間がないんですよ時間がない実践する時間がね
確保できないと思うんでこれは無理で次へ
スマホゲーム
現金者はどうですか無理告げ amazon とは2なサイトとは使うの禁止 c も
馴染みの店にで手に入れよ
ダラダラ家で過ごさなくて済むと思うからいいと思うよーするネットショッピング剣士
ってことですよねこれねいいと思うんですけど僕の方知ってますか引きこもりなんです
よいければ家から出たくない分
次コミュニケーシ同じ店弱で同じ多い直江これすごく多かったです今目に停止っていう
のはすごい良かったんですけども本目にを禁止することによって何が起きるかと言い
ますと小保方の子には歳ぐらいが断たれてしまうのでまぁ注ぎ始めかっこいい関係ねー
よあぁありがと爪切りの禁止来年の動画たぶんこんななってますからね目レベル6 e
噛み切るの禁止髪の毛を切らないことによるメリットがちょっと
ん
はから1年間よく軽種馬が野郎が帰ろうか動く記事ってことは新幹線に乗るときも移動
中とも全部畑かってことですよね
佐藤重心 i つければ月謝につける向けちゃい好きでも慶州年夏はと結構厳しいと
思うんですけども掃除機余裕なんですよあの僕に年前お菓子とジュース市内記述して
ましたから
をピンポイントでアイスクリームとか言われてもすごいともそのようなんでもう
ちょっとね
今までよりハードルをあげたいなって思ってる自分がいます
ド m かもしれません次コミュニケーション8たくさんあると思うけど忙しい始める
と
自生する時間形になっている実にバランスがとれた食事になりそうな気がするあくまで
個人の意見です
いろんな面で時間の短縮がめちゃくちゃできてるんで実際する時間がないんだけど
コンビニ禁止は多分本当にローダの頭皮の週1ぐらいに減るんじゃねーかぐらいの
ちょっと不安になるんであんまりススメではないですね
チヌのキー4みんなのため死なねえよ
なるためだ増税禁止賛成で spanky し結構ありだと思いますファンキーし結構
アリだと思ったんですけどもね今に難しいよねパンってどこまでがパンの1000匹か
ちょっと難しいところだったんで
ps 4を
なんだな一切の性的なことを禁ずる
菩薩のような一年を送るのです
ええええ
名音楽やら俺の日常が宿ってきた時間を奪わないでくれ
プロファイルの禁止許してこれは消しやこれはですね余裕でてるはお米はですね犯すと
重曹を掲出した僕からするとも麻生しまっ
すぎるの厳しい方にしたなんでさぁのたいというわけでみなさんたくさんのコメント
ありがとうございましたいろんなこれぞある中でやっ
パリ多かったのがですね牛丼禁止がすごい多かったです
ん
甘いな5枚お菓子ジュースをチンししラーメンを禁止し次はきゅんどんあなくないか
ラーメンが戻ってきた僕にとって牛丼禁止が結構余裕なんですよ多分分かんないです
けど正直厳しいかもしれませんが僕の中でも余裕だと思っていますが余裕で肇社長
2018年
ミクを引いてしまう
いんだよ俺でいいんだよ
バーイ
[拍手]
はいというわけでこの死刑実郎な肉でございますなぜこのチョイスに至ったか
3つほど理由があります8まず
何だろうなぁ何なのかとかして重要近世するのが妥当だと思ったんですけれどもそれだ
と
あの
ありそうじゃないですか何ここひとひねり加えてもっと上にいけないかと思ったところ
誘導を掲示するのではなくもうそれならいっそのことに来ざるやめちゃえばいいんじゃ
ねっていう達増に至ったので今買え
肉を禁止させていただきます1年間です
できるかが意外といけると思うんですよあと僕時代そんな肉が好きなタイプじゃないん
だよ好きですけど投資もまだやけに気に入ってないし
牛丼もで多分食ってないかなあとをに行くといつもへと豚肉鶏肉
牛肉あたりを記述しまして僕ちょっと色々調べたんですけどもお肉を食べないメリッ
トって結構あるみたいで何食ってなんか長に登ったりして悪玉菌を増やす原因になると
言われているみたいでございますなぜだお肉ためないと体質がいい意味で変わったり
するみたいです
アトミックを止めないとイライラやおこりっぽい性格が穏やかになると言われています
o
これは全然ねあのねやる価値あると思うんですよに'流れや政府臭くなるみたいなこと
を聞いたことがあるんでいい言葉だけじゃイヤにお肉を食べないことって結構いいこと
がいろいろあるみたいなんでちょっと1年号
子ぶってるよーと
じゃあ俺やばいじゃあ焼肉もいけないということで初級どの kc 唐揚げ禁止や
やり始めやるしかねぇ
やりない感じの菜食主義者になるって訳でもないので普通に卵とこの食べるし魚とかは
食べようと思ってるんでガッツリとしてお肉だけはノーと言うことにしたいと思います
あのすごいコメント欄でもお肉系子っていうのが多かったんで全然僕がやれると思い
ます今回は綺麗に1年というより1月1日まで禁止
します約1年ですねお肉を1年間食べなかったらどういう風に
からだとかなんか性格とか変化するのかを見ていこうと思います野ぎく検証で腕
なにはやけに原因でもなんか野菜とか食べてればいいってことでしょ
やってやるよもう
二いただけば
おっとり最後取るので
[音楽]
4分
これがあっ
2018年
肇社長が止めた最後のお肉であっ
うっ
うううう
い焼肉食べたいよー
ん
[音楽]